immer mehr ärzte krankenschwestern und
pflegepersonal steckt sich an also
diejenigen die ganz vorne an der
vordersten front kämpfen sollen gegen
das virus und wie hart dieser kampf auch
bei uns in deutschland werden könnte
zeigen diese bilder aufgenommen in
madrid die flure voller husten
corona patienten solche bilder gibt's
noch nicht in deutschland aber es zeigte
wie schwer
auch die krankenschwestern die ärzte
pflegepersonal unterstützung braucht
ganz praktisch vor allem schutzkleidung
in spanien ist es mittlerweile so dass
zwölf prozent der infizierten
pflegekräfte und medizinisches personal
ist genau deshalb klagt stellvertretend
für die mehr für das medizinische
personal verena graf physiotherapeuten
jetzt öffentlich die politiker an
mit ihrer freundin zum system das heißt
dass auch in dieser zeit unseren praxen
weiter
das heißt aber auch dass uns die
patienten oft bleiben dass es zu hause
bleiben es kommen keine neuen
unsere pläne sind leer wir können
allerdings nur geld verdienen wenn wir
rezepte bei den krankenkassen einreichen
und abrechnen
für nächste woche mussten wir kurzarbeit
anmelden
wie lange wir so überstehen würden
das weiß ich nicht es gibt kaum noch
ausreichend schutzkleidung infektions
mittel
wir wollen ja unsere patienten weiterhin
behandeln die die termine richtig nötig
haben
dazu brauchen wir allerdings
waffenschutz klein aber wir werden
übersehen die helfer brauchen hilfe
auch hier heimisch erbringer bei jenen
in dieser zeit bestmögliche
unterstützung vergessen uns nicht die
lieferungen seien schutzkleidung solchen
funktionsmittel sind nicht nur für die
krankenhäuser wichtig sondern auch für
uns wie kann das sein dass wir dabei
vergessen werden wo wir so dicht am
patienten arbeiten müssen
ich kann keine zwei meter
sicherheitsabstand zu meinen patienten
halten
als ich beim gesundheitsamt angerufen
habe und fragte wie ich nun
weiterarbeiten soll wurde mir gesagt ich
soll man patienten auf den bauch legen
das ist eine bodenlose frechheit wir
brauchen einen rettungsschirm
und zwar einen richtigen auf unsere
angestellten sind direkt betroffen
die haben auch angst um ihre gesundheit
überträger zu sein und ihre andere
anzustecken
ja und eine anklage diebe gleich
weitergeben konnten an den
niedersächsischen ministerpräsidenten
stephan weil vor kurzem hier im bild
interview das in einem so reichen land
wie deutschland nicht einmal
schutzmasken jetzt zur verfügung stehen
das liegt einfach daran weil der welt
bringt ja ein eine schutzmaske gibt es
ja wahrscheinlich haben denn förmlich
explodiert ist weil er immer auf der
welt die an irrsinn tour bedarf auf
einmal entsteht die preise sind übrigens
auch enorm gestiegen ich habe gehört und
das also um das zigfache wir sind im
moment in allen ländern und mit dem bund
intensiv dabei überall die beschaffung
wirklich zu beschleunigen auch die
bedarf
da weiß ich aus eigener aus eigener
kenntnis dass zum beispiel niedersachsen
die unterschiedlichsten drehte genutzt
werden um eine genügend schutzausrüstung
zu kommen und dann müssen wir wiederum
dann auch noch die schwierige frage der
verteilung klären das was wir eben
gehört haben das sagen mit vollem recht
zum beispiel auch viele pfleger in dem
altenheim
da der virus kassieren sollte was einen
unserer größten sorgen ist dann sind die
natürlich auch ganz unmittelbar mit dem
risiko konfrontiert also offen gesagt im
moment arbeiten allem intensiv an dem
thema schutzausrüstung aber keiner von
uns kann draußen er hätte übermorgen das
problem gelöst sein dass rich
schrittweise immer wieder von lieferung
zulieferung wirklich hoffentlich besser
wird paul ronzheimer im gespräch mit
stephan weil ministerpräsident von
niedersachsen
verena graf tschuldigung ist mir jetzt
zugeschaltet via skype pro grafe wir
haben ihren appell ihre anklage sehr
emotional sehr eindringlich gerade
gehört wir haben auf der anderen seite
den ministerpräsidenten gerade gehört
ist schon ein bisschen unterschied
reicht ihnen das was der
ministerpräsidentin da geantwortet hat
also im prinzip hat er ja gar nicht
richtig beantwortet zumal er auch schon
wieder von snagit kräften gesprochen hat
und nichts was physiotherapeut von uns
heilmittelerbringer auch da sind wir
gerade schon wieder übersehen oder
vergessen worden
es geht auch um zwei ringe wir brauchen
auch die schutzkleidung und nicht nur
die krankenhäuser und das flugpersonal
die sind auch wichtig diese natürlich
sehr sehr wichtig aber wir ja auch und
wir arbeiten ja so direkt am patienten
und ich muss schon sagen das ist mein
wunsch und das sind meine anstellung
liga also mehr schutzausrüstung habe ich
nicht und das muss ich nach jedem
patienten nicht schmeißen
es wäre schön gewesen wenn herr bei
aussagen hätte treffen können oder wird
dabei hätte sagen können
das war wiederum die in den anschlägen
auch die heime mit bedacht werden
sie fühlen sich tatsächlich vergessen
ist achtet von der politik in dieser
krise
oder glauben sie es ist ein versagen auf
mehreren gebieten und sie sind eine
gruppe von den dänen nicht geholfen wird
es ist natürlich sachen sind das
geheimnis erbringen haben sind schon
ewig im gesundheitssystem der winter ja
nicht ganz so wichtig ist ja immerhin
nachsteht und werden schon von vielen
seiten nicht wahrgenommen
ob es nun von den krankenkassen ist vom
gemeinsamen bundesausschuss und in
dieser situation ganz explizit auch
gesundheitsministerium
also sie gefährden tatsächlich bei jedem
patienten bei der ausübung ihrer
tätigkeit ihre eigene gesundheit ist es
richtig das kann man so sehen ich
schätze mich so gut es geht mit einem
mundschutz handschuhen und desinfizieren
mich mal der praxis also spricht die
behandlungsende die türklinken alles was
nötig ist und das ist das was wir tun
können
es reicht aber nicht aus und wir
brauchen auch nachschub von dem was
jetzt gerade verbraucht wird es ging um
bringen an desinfektionsmittel frech und
desinfektion hand desinfektion wunsches
und handschuhe drauf und wir kommen
gleich noch ein bisschen aus aber dies
in zwei wochen aussieht das weiß ich
nicht und was sollen wir denn machen
wer ist also notwendig und das direkt
bei ihnen die hilfe ankommt bei vera
graf ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich für
ihre einblicke
stephanie krüger ist mir jetzt so
geschaltet hier in berlin eine
pflegeheim chefin frau krüger sagen sie
mir bitte
wie sieht es bei ihnen aus wir haben
gerade von frau graf
ihr beispiel ihre erfahrungen gehört wie
sieht das ganz konkret heute bei ihnen
aus ja wir haben natürlich auch das
problem nicht nur corona ist unser
problem sondern auch die anderen keime
die zurzeit bei uns im heim sind die wir
laufen im moment auf reserve wir
brauchen das alles auch was wir noch
haben wir wissen natürlich auch nicht
wie lange dieser diese diese reserve
noch vorhanden ist wir sind ein relativ
großes unternehmen wir helfen uns
gegenseitig haben tolle teams tolle
mitarbeiter sie sind wir sind überall
auf der suche nach schutzkleidung und
mundschutz wir gucken auch verschiedenen
internetplattformen wo können wir was
bestellen wir klappern baumärkte ab wir
tun alles um unsere bewohner und
mitarbeiter zu schützen
aber das wäre es doch nicht sein dass
sie hätt's los gehen müssen und im
baumarkt nach schutz im mittelmaß
schutzkleidung ersuchen gibt es dann
nicht so was hätte man ja im kopf wenn
man an deutschland als entwickeltes land
denkt da gibt es einen zentralen
ansprechpartner eine zentrale nummer
vielleicht sogar eine e-mailadresse
heutzutage da schickt man hin was man
braucht und dann bekommt man das ihn
gibt es das auch in normalen zeiten
nicht
wir haben natürlich lieferanten diese
haben wir auch kontaktiert
wir wurden darauf hingewiesen dass keine
lieferungen mehr möglich sind sie
konnten uns auch nicht sagen wann diese
lieferung wieder wie man die lieferung
wieder da ist jetzt haben wir noch das
problem dass mir gestern mitgeteilt wird
das ist auch keine handschuhe mehr
lieferbar sind schwierige situationen
wie gesagt ich kann nur sagen
wir erhalten andere zusammen sind auf
der suche ich weiß dass die
senatsverwaltung bald mittel zur
verfügung stellen soll
und das ja auch gekauft wurde die frage
ist wann wird es an uns weitergegeben
und ich habe natürlich große angst dass
die mitarbeiter sich anstecken dass die
bewohner sich anstecken dass wir uns
alle anstecken
ja also da das hört sich stark nach
versagen an auf mehreren ebenen ihrer
meinung nach wer bei vielen liegt wer
hat tatsächlich versagt wenn wir jetzt
tatsächlich mal hier konkret werden das
kann man nicht sagen also das ist
schwierig einzuschätzen wer hat versagt
die frage ist natürlich der part ist ja
auch der ganzen welt auf einmal dadurch
wichtig ist würde ich sagen dass wir
alle zusammenhalten und jetzt uns gut
organisieren schnell mittel
bereitgestellt werden um auch natürlich
mitarbeiter und bewohner zu schützen
wie alle ich kann sagen als heimleitung
oder einrichtungsleitung es ist grausam
was passiert es in den in würzburg und
ich habe sehr sehr große angst davor und
die mitarbeiter auch und die angehörigen
natürlich auch von unseren bewohnern
also werde ich die befürchtung dass
würzburg sich wiederholen kann an
anderen stellen in anderen orten ich
danke ihnen für ihre deutlichen worte an
diesem abend stephanie krüger hier in
berlin ein pflegeheim chefin ganz
herzlichen dank